continúa la competencia oficial de este
festival de cannes hoy con dos películas
inspiradas en libros la primera de ella
es la historia de mi mujer de la húngara
indicó en red y ella es la cuarta mujer
en competencia en este festival de
cannes las otras tres son francesas su
película está basada en un libro de su
país también participan actores
franceses y alemanes y cuenta la
historia de un capitán de barco que está
en un bar y que apuesta que se va a
casar con la primera mujer que cruce la
puerta según la directora es una
película para entender a los hombres y
para decir adiós al patriarcado y si no
la segunda película está basada en un
cómic de un dibujante del new yorker y
es del francés jacques o díaz que conoce
bien el festival de cannes ganó ya una
vez la palma de oro se llama let's do la
ampliada y es un filme que está hecho en
blanco y negro en el barrio 13 de parís
o barrio asiático y cuenta la historia
de un grupo de amigos que son amigos
amantes y a veces las dos cosas y si no
hoy es 14 de julio día de francia y aquí
también se va a celebrar en cannes con
un espectáculo de fuegos artificiales
donde obviamente el tema es el cine